when you first took the role on seinfeld
you didn't know you were playing larry
david so you kind of played it like
woody allen yeah and you did that for a
while then you realized hey i'm playing
larry david aren't i well we we ran into
an early episode where
nothing made sense to me that the
situation seemed ludicrous on seinfeld
which situation was it i wish i could
remember the episode because you don't
see the first eight nine ten of them but
i remember we did the table read and i
went to larry and said larry please help
me this would never happen to anybody
but if it did
no one on the planet would react like
this and he said oh what are you talking
about this happened to me
exactly what i did and i i went oh wow
and then the bells went off i'm like oh
oh that's who i am oh okay right and
then i just started really observing him
and trying to pull as much of him into
me as i could you were aggressive about
getting that part you actually mailed
them an audition or something didn't you
oh is that what you heard i heard that
you i heard that you got your audition
by mailing them or no not at all no um i
knew nothing about it they had
apparently seen a lot of people in l.a
and there was nobody that i have the
list of people they had seen i i i've
heard some someone here tell me if any
of these you've heard yeah a larry
miller excellent community i actually he
was i went to network against larry
miller
brad hall who was on saturday night live
did not know that
david alan greer i did know that okay
nathan lane i did know that that's
interesting yeah and steve buscemi
wow
i've heard that yeah that's right they
reportedly all auditioned for the role
of george there are more paul schaefer
oh you're no kidding paul shaffer danny
devito was offered it at one point wow
chris rock was offered it at one point
wow um but you know for whatever reason
they didn't take it or that why do you
think they didn't take it i think a lot
of people didn't think seinfeld was
going to be a big hit in fact it wasn't
at first
that's so right i don't think it's that
they didn't think it was a hit i i think
in the case of danny he probably didn't
want to be
his career when we started sci-fi would
have been
that it's apex so he probably didn't
want to do a sidekick role right um
why chris wouldn't do it i don't know
maybe it didn't get to an offer stage i
don't know right
but so they had seen all these people
and uh they couldn't quite find it so
they called a casting director and said
just put some theater actors on tape
right and all i had was a couple of
pages of the script which read like a
woody allen film i had no context for it
so handsome
the glasses and i did you know the
blatant is blatant the woody allen's
like
is that how you did this
you were like
i can't even put this
didactic and
and i said i'll never see it again i
mean i made the tape and i went that was
just an exercise and nothing uh and a
couple weeks later got a call from from
nbc yes please we'd love to fly you out
and screen test you with jerry aren't
you amazed by that story in the sense
that no one auditions by doing woody
allen impression and it's like it seems
like a really dumb approach now that we
know the show well the truth was nobody
from new york ever got a tv gig that way
you're not meeting the producers you're
not meeting the star you're not meeting
so it's it's so abstract you have no leg
up you can't get a job that way which is
why i kind of went you just
i'll just throw this out i mean i'll
take a shot at something you're doing
the pages in a room by yourself and
you're like